my name is Allen Strickland Williams and
I'm going to tell you ten jokes do you
guys ever do this problem sometimes I
find that I in come off as pretentious
and off-putting to people who are
inferior to me and dumb just me I just
got one of those magic 8-balls I bought
cocaine from David Blaine you guys know
this they actually used to put cocaine
in coca-cola
do you know you still can stop if I've
been that neo dude
in the matrix I would have taken the red
pill and the blue pill because I'm
addicted to pills oh wow that's right we
got a gun issue in this country here's
what I don't get I don't get why guns
are legal in every state but we'd still
isn't like I've never been at a party
and been super stoked that someone
brought a gun
like hey keep it on DL but Kevin brought
a gun he'll go back pass it around hit
it when Missy Elliott wisely said put my
thing down flip it and reverse it I'm
pretty sure she was talking about her
mortgage
what else could that be it's baseball
season guys if you're ever had a
baseball game and you're bored and you
wanted to go by a little faster here's a
little tip just think about sex
when I die I think I want to be cremated
I think that's the polite thing to do
because if you get buried in a casket
you're basically just asking your
friends to help you move one last time a
lot of death heads in the crowd you guys
like impressions you wanna see
impression right this impression is of
Napoleon Bonaparte posing for his goofy
portrait okay we've seen Napoleon and
it's serious portrait like history
textbooks and museums
here's Napoleon Bonaparte posing for his
goofy portrait
[Applause]
it's the old Napoleon joke as you can
tell from my set I'm a pretty deep
thinker one thing I realized recently is
that the son is a loser
the son is that nerdy kid in the front
seat of class same spot every day
nothing better going on total buzzkill
if you look at the Sun too long you go
blind if you don't wear enough sunscreen
you get cancer and in a million years
the Sun will explode and destroy
everything we've ever known not very
tight meanwhile the moon is dope the
moon is so chill that sometimes at night
doesn't even show up it's got better
stuff going on sometimes it's all big
and red for no reason I'll wild it out
you know sometimes it's too hungover
it's got to chill in a hammock
so does it shows that during the day
crash the Sun SPOT like let's do it nerd
pre-gaming 2 p.m. the moon is cool the
only time that the Sun is ever cool is
during an eclipse when the moon is like
he's with me
[Applause]
you